What's going on? Versus in essence me, I
have for the Holy Spirit dwelling in me.
In the same way Jesus is actually also,
if we look at the New Testament But
Jesus was he
What? I'm nearly there. Jesus is also
filled with the spirit of God. We see
the spirit come down on Jesus and in
Jesus' baptism. So Jesus clearly was
already as the Bible describes son of
God before that baptism. Hang on. I
thought he was God. Huh? He was God or
son of God? No, he's God. So yes, as in
So no son of God? Son of God is what we
call his part of the trinity. No
brother, wait, wait cuz
when I learned English there's
difference between a son and a father
except if you're going to create another
language now. I mean in English language
say correctly. So Jesus is he God or a
son of God? Huh?
Jesus is he God or a son of God? He is
God but as in in the personhood of the
trinity he's the son of God.
Huh? Who is he? He's the son. So he's
son of himself? No. Huh? No, he's not.
Who's he son of then? He's not the He's
not the He's not the physical son of
anyone.
I mean maybe Mary if you want to go into
that but as in But no, what I'm saying
is Jesus son of God or is he God? If
he's son of God, he must be son of
himself because you already established
he's God. Well, I told you he's not a
literal son. So what do you mean by a
son? The son is a position not not a
because as in he's not he's not been
like you know, God had a baby. That's
his Okay, I know he's Is that the claim
that No, I'm not I'm sorry sorry sorry.
I mean in the sense of pre Let's say pre
pre Sorry. Pre-Jesus incarnation
it's not the case to say that Jesus was
like Okay, the father said you know, I'm
going to have a kid and there's the son.
You know this You know this is my son.
This is my son. Okay. In English
language He's beautiful. No, anyone will
tell me if you're speaking silly I'll
respect cuz in English language son has
four meanings.
We are utilizing English language,
correct? Or any language? So if if you
say to me what's your name by the way?
Mo. Mo, nice to meet you. My name is
Shamsi. Mo, if I say to you there's a
fridge and I point at the camera, you're
going to say Shamsi you're wrong. In
English language In English language
this is not a fridge, it's a camera. You
understand? So, when you say Jesus is a
son of God, when you go to English
language or any language, even Arabic
language, al-walad, or even it has four
meaning. One of them when a man and a
woman get together, produce a son, or
old man call a young man my son, or a
step son. Yeah. So, which one you are
utilizing for Jesus?
>> It's actually interesting very much that
you use the example of an old man
calling a younger man my My son, yes.
>> Yeah, so you're saying that you can call
me my son right now, right? Even though
we both know I'm not your biological
son. Yeah. And there's a sense in which,
in the same way, the Father and the Son,
that's the relationship they have. It's
not the biological son, but it's the
role he plays within
>> Is the Father older than him? That's why
he was something.
>> It's not It's not ages. It's about
positions. It's about responsibility.
>> Is there anyone Is there anyone higher
than God? There's no one higher than
God. All the time?
All the time. So, if Jesus
in the Bible Okay. said the Father is
greater than I, and in the Bible, on the
day of judgment, because I know you're
going to tell me in this earth, Jesus
was a man and a God same time. So,
according to Paul uh
uh uh uh gospel, he stripped off his his
uh divinity, and he humbled himself, he
became human. I'm talking about day of
judgment, on the day of resurrection,
day of judgment, when Jesus is fully
God. He's not He's not a man anymore. He
will submit himself to the Father. And
you just told me no one is higher than
God. But But I just showed you that
there is someone higher than Jesus. So,
either you're going to contradict
yourself Mhm. by saying no, or you're
going to be consistent saying, "You know
what? It's true. Jesus cannot be God."
>> Okay, put it this way, right? Put it
this way.
You have what In the UK system, you have
the king. He has
the power when it comes to Parliament.
And you have Parliament.
If
if
if the Parliament submits itself to the
king
Is the Parliament king?
Does that But this is my point.
>> Is the Parliament king? Is the
Parliament king? Yeah. Yeah, so the
Okay, but Jesus and the Father both are
calling God. So, your analogy is very
bad.
It's very very bad because
Yeah, but that's what we're talking
about. It's not about what you're trying
to say. What we're talking about that
you said the father is God, Jesus is
God, but clearly you said there's no
what? There's no one higher than God. I
just showed you from your own scripture
that the father is higher than Jesus.
But my point being really is to say that
therefore, because someone submits to
someone, that doesn't mean that they're
in essence higher than the other. Why he
submit to him? It implies it. It implies
it.
>> 100%. It could imply it, but I don't
think that's what
>> It does. It does.
Okay, let's read the context. The
context Jesus said read the context. The
The context Jesus said, "Everyone will
submit to me."
So, when the people submit to Jesus,
Yes. does that necessitate that Jesus
higher than them? Yes. Then Jesus said
he continue, "And I will submit to the
father." Does that necessitate the
father is higher than Jesus? But then
this is This is what I'm trying to say.
Same context. Now, you have to be
consistent.
They have TO BE CONSISTENT, YES.
HUH? My difference would be, for
example, okay, so let's say let's say
>> You have something in your head. Oh,
yeah, they keep coming. They keep
coming.
Let's say I have a colleague and they're
at the same level as me.
But yet we're doing a project and I I
submit to their leadership for that
project. That does not mean that they
are greater than me in one sense, but in
another sense they are because I
willingly submitted myself to their
leadership. In the same way, That's even
though it's of the same essence. Not
about Sorry, I hear [laughter] you.
That's a very very bad example. That's a
very bad example. You know why? I'll
tell you why, yeah? When it comes to
submitting to the leader leadership of
someone, Mhm. there's two things here.
Go on. Either because powerful than you,
Yeah. or you had you or both you agreed,
or both you you have you have the same
power, okay? Or you have the same power,
okay? That's why you cannot overpower
the other one, all right?
>> Yes. Or you're
with a colleague. So, when you look to
the father that you look to the father
and Jesus, Mhm. clearly Jesus Like I
said to you, listen to the context. Yes,
okay. People submit to Jesus. Yeah.
Jesus said, "Everyone will submit to
me." And I say to you, does that
necessitate Jesus higher than them? You
said, "Yes." I said, "The same context,
Jesus goes on to say, 'And I will submit
to the Father.'" And now, you're going
to change it. YEAH, BUT THAT'S
UNREASONABLE. THAT'S UNREASONABLE. YOU
KNOW WHAT? I'LL tell you something,
yeah. I respect No, no, you'll be so
good. Let me tell you something, yeah. I
respect what you're doing.
And this is what That's why
Allah told us in the Quran
the majority of the people of the
>> hellfire
or everyone that will be in the hellfire
forever are the arrogant ones.
Deep down, you know it's not making no
sense. I don't believe
>> But
trust me. I'll tell you I know it for a
fact. For a fact, you know it doesn't
make any sense. But what you're doing If
you don't
>> What you're doing, you have a sound
intellect which the creator has given
you and given all of all of us, and you
have your belief. So, what you're doing,
instead of saying, "You know what? I
have to doubt my belief." you start
going and guess what is known by
necessity. What is known by necessity,
that there's no one higher than God.
God doesn't not submit to no one.
Submission to if God submit to someone
else, that indicate it cannot be the
same God who everyone submit to him.
That's why in the Quran
Yes, brother, go ahead. Let me decide
what you're saying.
That's why in the Quran Allah said
Say Allah is one and unique.
Master, self-sufficient. Everything is
in need of him. He's not in need of
nothing.
He begets not, neither was he begotten.
And there's nothing like unto Allah.
This part This verse or this chapter
from the Quran, if I recite it to
someone that is a shepherd and someone
that is a professor or a doctor in
Oxford University, both of them would
understand it.
What you're saying
>> [laughter]
>> So all of them all of them all of them
will understand it. Why? Because Allah
is the God of the shepherd and the God
of the philosopher or a doctor or a
professor of the university. As for your
belief, many many Christians cannot
comprehend it. Because logically
inherently doesn't make any sense.
Which part? The part I don't like what
you said is that you called us as
Christians arrogant. When you in your
own belief, you that's what you believe.
So you can't really call us
No I'll tell you. Okay. If I said to you
I believe God knows everything. Do you
accept God knows everything all the
time? 100% Yes. All the time. No wait
wait sorry sorry sorry sorry all the
time. All the time. God nature to know
everything all the time. Then I said to
you but in the Bible God Jesus doesn't
know the hour. Now you just told me God
knows everything all the time. What does
it mean all the time? Mean all the time
always. So if I show you from your Bible
that Jesus doesn't know the hour either
you're going to say Shamsi I'm going to
humble myself he cannot be God anymore
because you already admitted God knows
everything all the time. So what are you
going to say now? That's what you say.
No wait wait wait hear him hear him now.
What are you going to say? Well I'm
tired now. YOU'RE TIRED NOW.
LET ME ASK YOU IF YOU WERE ON AN ISLAND
AND YOU HAD to logically think about God
how would you think about
That's right that's right mashallah.
You're right you're right you're right
you're right. Let's finish this one and
then we'll come back to that one okay?
Okay. So first of all I'd say God God
still knows everything because we
believe that the trinity is one God. So
even if you say the person of Jesus does
not know the Three in one. The father
It's like shampoo three in one. Sorry
just to say
On your earlier point, your idea of
submission invalidating one's one's one
being God, that's a that's a man-made
idea that we wouldn't subscribe to. We
don't necessarily believe that the same
way. In the same way when we believe in
submission in for example marriage, we
don't mean that invalidates the woman to
be of lesser value than man. We believe
God made male and female equal in his
eyes. And the Bible doesn't say that.
The Bible does say that. No, the Bible
said
every head of every man is Jesus. Every
head of every woman is a man. Then it
goes man Jesus. Then it goes so there's
hierarchy. THERE IS SOMEONE HIGHER THAN
SOMEONE.
Hierarchy but that's why I said
hierarchy doesn't necessitate a change
in value between men and women. No, no,
men and women what I'm saying in the
Christianity this is different topic who
if you want to address it on but what we
say to you brother that God have
absolute leadership. Absolute power.
Yes. Absolute power what does it mean?
Mean that everything
No, it means every human being with a
sound intellect. That it means if What
do you define as a sound intellect? Can
you show me where the father submit to
someone?
What? Yeah, scripture yeah.
He doesn't. Why always Jesus is
submitting? Why always Jesus is praying?
WHY ALWAYS JESUS PRAYING TO THE FATHER?
Why father never say Jesus help me? So
clearly we can see there is someone who
is the absolute true God and this is
what Jesus said. He said the only true
God is whom? Is the father which you
call the father which is this ambiguous
term if you want to discuss it afterward
but Jesus said the only true God is the
father. NOW IF I ASK YOU JESUS AS human
pay attention yeah. You believe there's
two nature of Jesus. Jesus as God and
Jesus as a man correct?
Yeah, okay. Jesus as human as a man
Jesus as a man. Yeah. Does he have a
God? Well, I'm not saying I believe in I
don't believe that it's like that. Hold
hold. I'm saying
100% 100%. Yes. Jesus
as a contradiction here, but Jesus as a
man does he have a god?
Jesus as a man does he have a god?
But I just told you that they're not
separate. I'm asking you. I'm just
asking you. Sorry, sorry, sorry, they're
they're not separate. So does he have a
god? Does he Well, he he is god.
>> He is god. Jesus said Jesus said What
are you saying? He has to accept Jesus
as a god. He said
Nobody said he has no He said he's god.
>> No, I said he is god. He said he's god,
yeah. Did your god have a god? Huh? Did
your god have a god? He doesn't have a
god. In the Bible in the Bible IN THE
BIBLE JESUS SAID, "I'm going to my god
and your god." So Jesus, according to
Jesus' wording, he has a god. According
to the Christian here, he doesn't have
god. So who's speaking the truth?
What's different? As in the way I feel
like the way we're using the term god is
different. Jesus said god. That is he
used it. Okay, fine. Yes, Jesus says
Jesus says my god.
>> to your god. He's talking to his
disciples. To your god and my god. So
the god of the disciples is the same god
of Jesus.
>> Yes, okay, fine. I agree with that. But
I'm saying and he says
>> So you're wrong when you say he has a
god. No, no, no, no, listen. He said he
said And Jesus even says on the cross he
says, "My god, my god, why have you
forsaken me?" Why have you forsaken me?
Exactly, exactly. Even though the other
way he's saying it. And so what I'm
saying is yes, there is a sense in which
Jesus has a god, fine. I I will concede
that. But what I'm saying is that
doesn't invalidate the fact that Jesus
is also god. Does god have a god?
Brother, does Does Brother, does the god
have a god?
Okay.
But he said he HAS A GOD, JESUS. YEAH.
He's god, he's god. Yeah, HE SAYS THAT.
HE'S GOD, BUT HE HAS A GOD. YES, HE DID
SAY THAT. SO HIS GOD HAS A GOD, SO
THERE'S TWO GODS THEN. There Jesus is
Okay.
Okay. Wait, wait, wait, wait. ARE YOU A
KING? NO, NO. Are you a king? No, no,
NO, NO, NO. NO, BROTHER, are you a king?
Sorry, sorry. Sorry, please, please. Are
you a king? I'm not a king. Okay. If you
are a king
>> PRINCE, THOUGH. NO, YOU'RE A KING. IF
YOU'RE a king and he's a king, how many
kings you have? If you're a king and a
king, two kings. Jesus is god and Jesus
said he has a God. How many Gods?
>> No, no, no, no, no, no.
BUT SAYING SAYING SAYING
BUT GOD IS TWO KINGS.
THAT'S WHY ISLAM IS SPREADING. THAT'S
WHY
that's why Christianity is dying.
IT IS IT IS.
BROTHER GOOGLE IT.
OKAY, GOOGLE IT. THERE IS article in
newspaper there is churches are turning
into swimming pools. No no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no NO NO NO.
>> CHURCH
CHRISTIAN HAD ENOUGH THEY WERE SLEEPING.
ALSO ALSO also also also we bought
church in East London we turned it into
a mosque to mosque. We bought church in
German town America we turned it into a
mosque. We bought church in Birmingham
turned it into A MOSQUE.
EVEN ON THAT CAN I SAY FIRST OF ALL?
THAT'S WHY IT'S DYING CHRISTIANITY. We
are not trying to rule this world. In
this idea of oh we want church here and
there that's not what we believe in. God
is a spirit. God is within us it's not
about how many church buildings we have.
It's not about domination. That's what
THE BIBLE SAYS.
THE BIBLE SAYS DOMINATE. JESUS JESUS IS
GOING TO COME BACK AND
in the meantime we know Sorry Jesus is
going to come back to do what? Jesus is
going to come back to do what? Rule the
world. To dominate?
Yeah but But Islam is about domination.
No no no no no no no no no I'm saying at
this current moment in time You keep
contradicting yourself brother. You
contradict yourself more than that. Who
is HIS NAME? NIGEL FARAGE. YOU'RE GOING
TO NIGEL FARAGE? YEAH YOU CONTRADICT
YOURSELF MORE THAN HIM.
NO NO YOU.
I SAID YOU CONTRADICT YOURSELF MORE THAN
HIM. No no no I'm not contradicting
myself. I'm telling you I'm saying about
now it's not about domination. Jesus
going to come back. The victory is
assured for us. So for us it's not about
how do we dominate now. Whereas I think
this is a very different kind of mental
way of thinking about religion compared
to you guys where there's a bit of a
sense of we want submission domination
now. We're not looking for it now cuz we
know it's already going to come. We
already know the victory is assured for
us. And so the way we live is different.
We live in the light of being able to be
weak in a way because we know that in
Christ we have strength. We know that in
Christ we will be raised from the dead.
So we don't need to fear. Okay, but
there's no church here by the way. I
respect you preaching up. The point HERE
IS
I WANT TO SAY to you what you saying
again you haven't read the Bible. If it
was not about spreading Christianity,
Jesus said to his disciples to go and
spread it.
So hang on so so BROTHER ONE SECOND.
CUZ I WANT TO
>> [laughter]
>> HAVE RESPECT. MO, clearly you have not
read the Bible. That's not true. Clearly
because again again when I told you
about spreading I WILL TELL YOU HEAR ME
OUT HEAR me out. Hear me out.
Hear me out. When I tell you about
spreading I don't disrespect I respect
the reality. Okay. So I am
so what I was going to say to you is
spreading. What the reason I said that
because now
the time we living in Yeah. you cannot
try to manipulate the manipulate the
people by using the Bible by yourself.
Now
Christians are meeting with the Muslims
and the Muslims they have powerful
questioning questions to question the
Christians. Yeah. That logically any
human being with a sound intellect
regardless of your belief, regardless of
where you from, with a sound intellect,
if you say to me Yeah. God knows
everything all the time Yeah. at the
same time he does not know the hour I'll
tell you you are contradict that's a
paradox because it it is a paradox.
Okay. It is a paradox. It cannot be both
of them true.
>> And I told you I All right, take care of
yourself. May Allah help you. Take care
of yourself. Nice talking to you. You
know what Okay.
No I don't want to shake your hands cuz
you want to shake my hand. You didn't
want to shake my hand first. Take care
of yourself.
No no you said may Allah may Allah help
you no doubt.
Take care of yourself.